du sport on ne reprendra pas le sport
professionnel dans des conditions
normales il n'y a que le football
aujourd'hui qui restent encore accrocher
à cet espoir de pouvoir finir la saison
joué meules le tout rejoindre dans les
sprints et parmi les autres sports
professionnels français
tous ont pris la décision de ne pas
jouer la crise touche tout le monde et
je compte qu'il aurait route il aussi
votre aide l'infection revenir à plus de
mesure et faire en sorte de construire
en fait un business soit aussi plus
durable et pour diminuer pour quelques
la plaine morte à deux voix qui tremble
très chic et sport c'est la rue donc si
on peut retrouver tout ce qu'il est les
terrains libres et pour l'heure pas
votre passion ça vous va dire qu'à vivre
de numéro
[Musique]
l'état d'urgence sanitaire prolonger de
deux mois en france le texte de loi sera
en débat au parlement la semaine
prochaine
les personnes arrivant sur le sol
français auront obligation de s'isoler
en quarantaine les agents de sécurité
dans les transports auront le droit de
verbaliser ceux qui ne porte pas de
masque
un reflux de l'épidémie s'installe en
espagne
à l'instar de la france le pays prévoit
un déconfinement par étapes et très
prudent madrid autorise un nouvel
assouplissement de son confit
très strictes imposées le 14 mars avec
des sorties sportives individuelles le
nombre de morts en italie lui est
reparti à la hausse ces dernières 24
heures avec 474 décès supplémentaires
aux etats unis le déconfinement
progresse le virus
aussi malgré deux mille morts en moyenne
par jour de nombreux états lève en
partie leurs restrictions
manifestation anti confinement
for me et donald trump qui annonce en
personne le feu vert des autorités
sanitaires pour l'utilisation en urgence
d'un antiviral après un essai
encourageant sur la durée de
rétablissement des malades
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi le gouvernement
français a prolongé ce matin en conseil
des ministres la loi d'urgence sanitaire
prolongée jusqu'au 24 juillet prochain
elle est entrée en vigueur le 24 mars
dernier mais sa levée le 23 mai a été
jugée prématurée par l'exécutif
le texte sera donc débattu au parlement
lundi et mardi il vise à élargir le
cadre juridique pour y intégrer des
enjeux du déconfinement voyez les
précisions devant l'elysée de notre
reporter thomas bonnin le gouvernement a
donc entériné la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire pour une période de
deux mois jusqu'au 24 juillet prochain
il s'agit selon lille et veyran
d'élargir le cercle ou juridiques
notamment par rapport aux déconfinement
avenir partir du 11 mai parmi les
mesures qui ont été énoncées par le
ministre de la santé il ya cette mesure
de quarantaine et d'isolement qui ne
concernera finalement que les personnes
qui arrivent sur le territoire national
qu'ils soient français ou étrangers ils
seront soumis à une 14/n ou à des
mesures d'isolement comme l'a précisé le
ministre de la santé qu'on épouse pour
les personnes qui rentreraient sur le
territoire national dans les outre-mer
ou encore ce set 14 n obligatoire elle
va concerner des gens qui arrivent c'est
souvent ce sont souvent d'ailleurs des
français qui sont partis à l'étranger
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
depuis longtemps qu'ils n'ont peut-être
même d'ailleurs pas de logement en
france mais qui souhaitent revenir 7 14
n elle est imposée à toute personne qui
rentre sur le territoire dès lors
qu'elle fait le souhait de rentrer sur
le territoire
elle sera organisée avec les moyens de
l'état j'ai parlé d'un décret qui sur
proposition des scientifiques définira
la durée les conditions d'accès aux
biens essentiels le suivi médical qui
sera organisée autre point
particulièrement attendu et détailler
aujourd'hui par le ministre de la santé
c'est ce système d'information afin de
répertorier des personnes malades et les
contacts qu elles ont pu avoir ce que le
ministre de la santé appelle le contact
tra singh des données médical et non
médical qui vont donc être récoltés
propose d'écouter un nouveau le ministre
de la santé oliveira il s'agira de
collecter des données d'ordre non
médical mais aussi des données d'ordre
médical pour les porter à la
connaissance d'un grand nombre de
revenant avec cinq étapes distinctes
tout d'abord le recueil des résultats
des tests lorsqu'ils sont positifs par
les laboratoires ensuite ce qu'on
appelle le tracking de niveau 1 qui sera
exercée par les médecins les
professionnels de santé de premier
recours
en ville comme à l'hôpital pour définir
le premier cercle des cas contacts
potentiels d'une personne malade le
tracking de niveau 2 lui sera organisée
par l'assurance maladie
il vise à enrichir la liste des contacts
potentiels
au delà de ce premier cercle de vérifier
qu'aucune personne potentiellement
malades n'ai pu échapper aux premiers
traces hing et donné des consignes
prophylactique aux intéressés à noter
que ces informations seront mises à la
disposition des brigades qui vont donc
être mises en place comme l'avait
annoncé le premier ministre et ces
informations seront indépendantes de
l'application stop qu'ovide comme l'a
expliqué olivier avait rang et puis
christophe castanet a également détaillé
quelques mesures avec notamment
l'obligation du port du masque dans les
transports en commun les agents dans les
transports pourront verbaliser les
manquement à cette règle
christophe castaner qui explique qu'il
n'y aura pas d'interdiction de
déplacement entre les départements ou
les communes puisque comme il l'a
expliqué le virus s'affranchit des
frontières administratives au total cet
article dans ce projet de loi qui sera
présenté lundi au sénat avant d'être
débattu à l'assemblée nationale ce sera
mardi prochain et voyez ce qu'en pense
jérôme marty il est médecin et président
de l'union française pour une médecine
libre et elle est pas tellement
surprenante parce qu on sait qu on it un
moment de fragilité notre société on ne
sait pas du tout si il va y avoir cette
fameuse deuxième bague ou non on sait
très bien qu'il n'ya pas de vaccin qu'il
n'y a pas de traitement qu'il ya une
très faible partie de la population qui
est immunisé et que donc tout à craindre
si les mesures barrières ne sont pas
respectés par la population et si la
population n'est pas mise en capacité de
faire ces mises en arrière je veux dire
par là que la population n'est pas tout
les moyens de protection il va falloir
que les masques sont mis à à
une disposition de la population et que
les solutés hydro-alcooliques soit
également présents notamment dans les
lieux recevant du public dans les
transports en commun etc
je crois qu'on repousse cela on l'emmène
tient de deux mois et cet état d'urgence
est nécessaire de façon à pouvoir réagir
s'ils donnent dès qu'il y avait à
remettre en place malheureusement un
compliment
les maires de france reste
particulièrement inquiet avant la
réouverture des écoles le 12 mai
prochain
ils s'inquiètent notamment de possibles
poursuites pénales s'ils n'arrivaient
pas à appliquer les mesures sanitaires
imposées par le gouvernement
pour l'instant aucune disposition
apparaît dans le projet de loi d'urgence
sanitaire présenté ce matin c'était
pourtant une demande des élus locaux
vous voyez la réaction de philippe
laurent lemaire udi de saut il est
également secrétaire de l'association
des maires de france
j'avais cru comprendre et nous allions
comprendre que les discussions que nous
avions avec le gouvernement permettrait
d' à serrer dans le projet de loi
d'urgence qui sera débattu à partir de
demain au parlement une disposition
particulière concernant cette
responsabilité pénale des mères j'ai cru
comprendre que malheureusement le
gouvernement n'avait pas choisi
d'insérer cette disposition dans le
projet de loi
nous verrons ce qu'il ce qui dicte ce
qui se dira mais en tout cas je crains
que si cette disposition d'allègement de
la responsabilité pénale encore une fois
pendant cette période bien particulière
n'est pas prise
de nombreux maires seront amenés à
refuser la réouverture de leur école
nous avons un travail considérable pour
mettre en place serait de cette
réouverture des écoles à travail que
nous faisons en partenariat avec les
fonctionnaires de l'éducation nationale
qui sont par nos communes
ça se passe bien en général on est bien
ce film vers l'action sur le terrain
mais par ailleurs nous avons le
sentiment quand les faits au niveau
national eh bien les préoccupations que
nous exprimons et même parfois des avis
que nous pourrions exprimées ne sont pas
pris en compte non pas au niveau local
mais au niveau des décisions général et
des décisions nationales
c'est ce que j'appelle décentralisation
d'exécution mais savait pas une
décentralisation de codécision avec le
pouvoir central
ça n'est pas nouveau je constate qu'à
l'occasion de ces
de cette crise est bien la situation ne
s'améliore pas et avec cette crise
le vélo a beaucoup de succès notamment
par crainte de prendre les transports en
commun ils se développent également vous
allez le voir dans le monde du travail
depuis le début du confinement il a été
mise au service des commerçants pour
livrer les produits notamment via une
plateforme en ligne
luis carballo et quand un mot clair ils
ne font pas tous le même métier mais ils
partagent la même passion le vélo depuis
le début du confinement l'association
les boîtes à vélo s'est donné pour
objectif d'aider commerçants et artisans
à maintenir leur activité
loin de leur profession exercée dans
leur vie quotidienne ils se sont
reconvertis en livreur le temps du
confinement avaient bien merci
le service démarre depuis quelques
quelques semaines et on a effectivement
de plus en plus de demandes de clients
qui souhaitent être livrés à domicile
puisque les restaurants sont fermés
après avoir agi de manière bénévole dans
un premier temps l'association propose
désormais une formule payante avec des
tarifs abordables
depuis le 17 mars les commandes
explosent notamment celles liées à la
restauration la livraison à domicile a
été la bouée de sauvetage des
restaurateurs rester en activité pendant
le confinement ou que c'est très
intéressant surtout sur le principe de
livraison
ça permet de garder le contact avec nos
clients aussi de les rassurer pour ce
qui est finalement un peu por te rendre
en boutique et donner un goy possibilité
effectivement des circuits les plus
rapides nom de stationner plus
facilement c'est un moyen de locomotion
qui est non polluant aujourd'hui et qui
aux heures de pointe finalement va
beaucoup plus vite que la voiture et qui
permet de la livraison de proximité
beaucoup plus facilement le vélo s'est
révélé être un excellent moyen de
livraison rapide économique et non
polluant
des atouts qui pourrait être pérennisée
après la pandémie et qui donnerait au
vélo une place prioritaire dans le
transport urbain de proximité
c'est le pari de caroline fondatrice de
la branche lyonnaise des boîtes à vélo
ce qui est une ouverture ça va donner
aux artisans les commerçants la
possibilité d'envisager un nouveau
business avec la livraison à la porte du
client particulier
parce qu'en fait on se rend bien compte
que le vélo aidé à prendre une place de
plus en plus importante
et finalement je pense que cette fuite
c'était un peu un révélateur
depuis sa création en 2015 à nantes les
boîtes à vélo se sont pérennisés un peu
partout en france
au point de fonder la première
fédération des travailleurs à vélo la
france qui a vécu hier un 1er mai très
particulier sans défilé syndical
une fête des travailleurs qui fera donc
date par sa tranquillité
même si on a entendu quelques bruits de
casseroles regarder
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au volet judiciaire le parquet de paris
a ouvert une enquête pour violences et
menaces après l'agression dont a été
victime le polémiste eric zemmour alors
qu'il faisait ses courses dans paris le
journaliste aurait été suivie par un
individu qui lui aurait proféré des
insultes l'homme dit même lui avoir
craché dessus
l'enquète a été confiée à la brigade de
répression de la délinquance contre la
personne
un déconfinement très prudent en espagne
qui compte 25 mille morts le chef du
gouvernement a annoncé que le port du
masque sera obligatoire dans les
transports dès lundi prochain les
sorties sportives où les loyers sont de
nouveau autorisées après un confinement
extrêmement strictes imposées depuis le
14 mars
c'est le cas notamment à madrid écoutez
mais c'est génial je me sens très bien
la nuit c'est vrai que ce sont des
mesures très extrême mais c'est comme ça
il faut faire ce qu'ils nous disent de
faire parce qu'ils connaissent la
situation mieux que nous cette petite
libération fait beaucoup de bien et
quand les choses iront mieux me sentir
ont tous mieux également
bon je reprends un peu le sport est
d'abord de la marche parce que c'est
mettre à courir directement va être un
peu compliqué après autant de temps mais
je me sens bien depuis quelques jours
j'ai pu me balader un peu parce que j'ai
une fille mais la reprise est dure oui
c'est compliqué
aux etats unis le déconfinement
progresse également et le virus aussi
malgré deux mille morts en moyenne par
jour de nombreux états sont en train de
lever en partie leurs restrictions
il ya même des manifestations anti
confinement en californie donald trump a
annoncé en personne le feu vert des
autorités sanitaires pour l'utilisation
en urgence d'un antiviral après des
essais encourageants
grégoire doucet
la sortie du confinement prend forme
outre atlantique 35 des 50 états
américains s'apprêtent où ont déjà
commencé à lever certaines mesures de
restriction au texas les commerces dont
les restaurants ouvrent à condition de
se restreindre à 25% de l'activité
habituelle est de mettre en place une
série de protections contre le virus
nous avons décidé d'installer des
panneaux en plexiglas autour du bar et
nous en avons aussi au stand des
hôtesses tout en oubliant tous les
employés vont porter un masque et des
gants et nous on est vraiment toutes les
précautions possibles à new york chicago
ou encore ici à los angeles
les manifestations anti confinement se
poursuivre ouvrez la californie scandent
les contestataires drapeau américain et
pancartes à la main ils réclament la
levée des privations de liberté doit
pouvoir sortir le virus est là pour un
bon moment comme la grippe à leur rôle à
on doit manifester ce n'est pas pire que
la grippe
bien sûr ce n'est pas la grippe mais ce
n'est pas pire ceux qui sont malades
doivent rester chez eux et se soigner
mais il faut que les gens en bonne santé
puissent travailler sortir et avoir une
vie sociale
le gouvernement essaie de gouverner nos
vies et il faut qu'on résiste
d'autres états sont en train de rouvrir
kevin nous sommes doit suivre la marche
sinon il va tout perdre
il va perdre tous ceux qui le
soutiennent parallèlement à cette
contestation la course aux traitements
s'accélère l'agencé américaine du
médicament en accord avec
l'administration trump a autorisé
l'utilisation du médicament expérimental
rem daisy vire le locataire de la maison
blanche estime prometteur ce traitement
qui pourrait accélérer de plusieurs
jours la guérison des patients gravement
atteints par le virus
je suis heureux d'annoncer que gilead a
reçu une autorisation d'utilisation
d'urgence de l'agencé américaine du
médicament pour le rêve d y virent et
vous savez de quoi il s'agit car ça fait
la une dans les journaux et les médias
depuis quelques temps un médicament
important pour les patients hospitalisés
attendu coronavirus elle c'est vraiment
une situation très prometteuse si la
levée des mesures drastiques de
restriction s'accélère les bilans
quotidiens reste lourd dans le pays le
plus touché au monde avec près de 2000
nouvelles victimes chaque jour
et voyez ce qu'en pense etienne decroux
l'ifi les virologues et directeur de
recherche au cnrs
c'est un médicament qui avait été
développé déjà et il y avait déjà eu des
échecs il est effet contribuer à l'ap
donc illégalement des essais qui ont été
faits avec ce médicament contre le
coronavirus à le nouveau maire sud oncle
sarge comme vous qui avait nagé en 2003
sur des singes est donc l'un des
indications différents tels qu'ils sont
assez solides chez les singes depuis un
an et séparation avait montré que
c'était un médicament antiviral qui
avait une assez bonne efficacité chez
les sages pour autant que la prise du
médicament soit très précoce après
l'inoculation du virus ce qui avait été
montré dans les expériences
préliminaires pour être précis c'est que
si on prétraités les singes avant les
infectés avec le virus
il était complètement protéger de
l'infection par le virus et plus on
attendait le moment où les 100 javel est
remporté par le lieu et le moment où on
allait leur délivrer la thérapeutique
plus les ferons ça peut être anti viral
du virus était faible et donc on
s'attend évidemment à ce que chez les
mêmes les choses ne soient pas très très
différents on en vient à cette tribune
publiée par des officiers de haut rang
sur le site de capital.fr tous sont
membres du cercle de réflexion
interarmées et il appelle je cite à se
libérer de l'emprise américaine pour se
rapprocher de moscou
il considère le prochain exercice de
l'otan comme une provocation contre la
russie
les signataires dénoncent je cite encore
de vieux réflexes de guerre froide et
conteste la participation de la france
notamment à ses manoeuvres militaires
écoutez le général jean claude allard il
est justement l'un des signataires de
cette tribune je ne fais pas fier au
fond de ce cheminement
on se rapproche mais bon nécessairement
on voit bien que aujourd'hui l'occident
si je puis dire est en relations tendues
avec moscou et que l'idée est bien
entendu d
terminez s'il y a toujours lieu d'avoir
et de d2 de maintenir cette tension et
d'examiner de quelle façon on peut pour
nous français en tant qu'européens
recontre reproposer un rééquilibrage
entre les différentes puissances
on sait que nous avons d'un côté la
chine on sait que nous avons d'un côté
de la côte et les états unis staff est
indiscutable au milieu il ya l'union
européenne l'union européenne à ce qu'on
porte le poids qu'elle veut dire la voir
et en europe il ya la rue et donc il
faut examiner comment la russie terre et
amplifie ce deux poids de l'union
européenne la crise sanitaire en afrique
à présent avec 1645 décès et près de
40000 contamination déclaré le continent
et qui compte un milliard d'habitants
semble relativement épargnée par la
propagation du coronavirus la plupart
des pays du continent ont semble-t-il
bien anticipé l'arrivée de ce virus sur
le territoire
beaucoup ont pris des mesures notamment
le confinement de la population bien
encore la mise en place d'un couvre-feu
est l'afrique du sud et l'egypte reste
des pays les plus touchés sur le
continent africain et pour en parler
nous sommes avec mouminine jaun et
consultant en santé publique
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct de ouagadougou
comment expliquez vous le fait que
l'afrique soit relativement épargné on
avait annoncé une catastrophe elle
n'aura pas lieu selon vous je pense que
la catastrophe ne l'a pas lieu et les
données statistiques juste marre même
ciel sont pas très fiables à cause du
fait de la faible capacité de testing de
nos pays montre que la catastrophe
normalement ne l'a pas lieu et les
explications sont assez nombreuses déjà
le fait que les pays africains ont pu
apprendre quand même des erreurs des
autres pays qu'ils ont précédé peut
expliquer le fait que nous ayons moins
de deux cas et aussi il faut voir que la
population africaine est assiégé et
quand on sait que provident 19 est
beaucoup plus grave chez les populations
les plus âgés on peut naturellement
comprend que les pays africains soit
plus protégé vous avez plus de 60% de la
population qui a moins de 25 ans et donc
du coût à supporter quand on regarde la
france ou en italie pour les plus
touchées avaient en moyenne 75 ha ça
peut vraiment s'explique ainsi il ya
aussi l'affairé densité des pays
africains et des tpe des habitants au
niveau des pays africains vous avez en
afrique que la densité surtout de 43
habitants par kilomètre carré par là que
dans les pays où rien on a environ plus
de 100 à 150
habitants par kilomètre carré c'est les
explications qui peut tenir la
circulation aussi de la population ça
paraît dans mon pays africains déjà
supprimé moins que dans les autres pays
et donc ça peut aussi être des facteurs
qui expliquent cette ces chiffres que
nous a parlé aussi beaucoup de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine que les
africains prennent puisque c'est aussi
un traitement contre le paludisme
vous pensez que ça jouait également ou
pas du tout je ne passe pas je pense que
peut-être d'autres les études futures en
plus d'informations par rapport à
l'utilisation de la technologie mais mon
avis reste mesuré par rapport à cette
dimension que la coûteuse qu'une
histoire
le facteur explicatif et du fermi tôt
dans l'année parce que je pense aussi
sicile et les choses ont empiré l
afrique évidemment ne pourrait pas faire
face est-ce qu'elle a été est ce que
l'aide promise notamment et l'aide
demandée par à part l'om s arrive pour
faire face au cas ou pas du tout
alors je ne sais pas vraiment mais je
sais que les pays africains se
débrouille assez bien et que quand on
regarde les l'adoption de comportements
des mesures barrières les gens tendent à
les adopter en espère que justement les
gens peuvent attendre de mieux en mieux
conscience de l'enjeu de la maladie et
qu'il devra et qu'il va adopter les
comportements qui va permettre d'éviter
que thomas juste marre d'aller chaos
quel est le comportement de la
population est ce qu'il y a des craintes
s comme comme en france d'ailleurs et
comment est ce que vous voyez la
situation dans la vieille europe et
d'afrique
alors oui on a fait habituellement ces
convois comme image c'est que le
confinement aux régates que les gens
inspectent énorme mal règles au niveau
des pays européens et que c'est ceux qui
ont peu de différence chez nous
cependant quand on voit ce dernier tarde
que les règles qui ont été démis
zoonekynd a déjà pour massa manifesté
pour demander à ce qu'on allège juste
marrer l'aide pour qu'il pût semaine et
hakima activités du tout les jours et je
me dis que si on arrive à faire
respecter
carrément les mesures de battre les
mesures barrières les populations pour
artix progresse
marc wehrlin à amène à leurs activités
quotidiennes
parce que justement dans nos pays le
confinement total est très très
difficile à appliquer parce que les
populations qui vivent en général au
jour le jour
arena les activités ne pourront pas
soutenir longtemps de rester chez eux
ces actifs est ce que les frontières
sont fermées entre les pays et est ce
que l'afrique contrôle également
évidemment les vols en provenance de
l'étranger
bon ce qui concerne le burkina faso a
bouffé des frontières sont fermées en
dehors de fret et je pense que ça
continue effectivement ralentir la
propagation de la wii les gens sont
assez faire un placement
et comment est ce que les déplacements
de population notamment l'immigration on
en a parlé beaucoup en europe est ce que
ces personnes finalement maintenant ne
partent plus depuis que l'europe et est
contaminé par coronavirus est-ce que ça
râle en pied en tout cas cette
immigration vous pensez
ben c'est pas mon impression mais je
pense que le fait même que les
frontières soient refermées les gens
sont obligés de rester chez eux et doit
amener faire de fait que 8,19 est assez
catastrophique dans les rangs les gens
savent ils préfèrent rester
effectivement jeu en attendant que la
tempête passe on a même vu des nos
frères africains quitter l'italie et
l'unita qui n'obéit mental de voir ce
qui va se passer plus tard près donc
c'est le mouvement inverse qui s'est
produit après qu'un pays aujourd'hui en
afrique est le plus touché qu'elles
paient le moins touché alors je n'ai pas
les chiffres exacts mais je sais que le
nigeria l'afrique du sud sont assez
touchés et mais de bon cc c'est ce que
j'ai actuellement qu'en chiffres en tête
je sais limite à la merci beaucoup il
n'y en ait d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en direct de ouagadougou donc
au burkina faso merci de votre
intervention sur rt france c'est la fin
de ce journal
restez avec nous on se retrouve dans une
demi heure pour un nouveau point sur
l'information à suivre nos magazines
d'actualité
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique